moi c'est pas apparemment parce que
j'arrive avec des chiffres et là j'ai
l'offre d'EDF hier pour un de mes sites
de 14000 il me propose 63000
63000 pour un des sites de 14000 63000
et ça c'est des vrais chiffres enfin
c'est pas inventé
ça c'est un petit monsieur de l'adresse
qui nous a fait l'amortisseur donc tout
le monde parle les super aides pour les
boulangers sur les 63000 vous avez 8600
euros d'aide
si vous voulez j'ai aussi ramené mon
bilan
et sur mon bilan en fait
quand j'ai payé mes 10 salariés
quand j'ai payé mon approvisionnement
mes loyers mes charges à la fin de mon
bilan il me reste 50000 euros 50000
euros cette année on a décidé d'investir
on a refait notre magasin on a investi
120.000 euros on a pris un crédit sur ce
6 ans on fait travailler j'ai envie de
dire les commerces locaux les artisans
du coin
donc l'année prochaine il me restera 30
000 de bénéfices 30 000 je paye pas ma
facture d'EDF exactement qui augmente
dans ce pourcentage là
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire pas de
salaire vous versez même pas de ça
veut dire réduire les effectifs
les effectifs ça veut dire mettre
l'entreprise en danger enfin de toute
manière on passera pas une année donc on
a eu une réunion il y a deux semaines
avec Bruno Le Maire l'amortisseur ils
savent même pas le calculer fin
ils savent même pas de quoi ils nous
parlent et quand ils nous parlent d'aide
c'est ridicule enfin c'est impossible à
entendre non mais là ce que vous nous
dites c'est du concret on comprend tout
à fait et puis quand je dis quand on a
une entreprise quand on a des
boulangeries on prévoit l'avance on se
dit voilà on va faire ça on va investir
là dessus on attend d'employé on va
faire tant dans l'année quand vous avez
une dépense de soi de de parce que ça
passe de ces 60000 euros de plus en fait
c'est 70 000 euros de plus en fait par
an entre les deux boulangeries c'est ça
vous êtes battus c'est fini il m'a
terminé tout ce que vous avez mis en
place s'effondre et il paraît que vous
avez même honte de dire à vos employés
que que vous pourriez que vous n'arrivez
pas à vous en sortir une entreprise
comme la nôtre c'est une petite
entreprise familiale et on se connaît
tous
moi j'ai alors j'ai alerté la presse la
semaine dernière j'ai alerté les députés
puis il y a une de mes vendeuse qui a vu
l'article dans la presse il est sorti
sur le Web avant que ben voilà celui là
avant que j'ai le temps de les prévenir
est direct à 22h30 elle m'envoie en me
disant point d'interrogation comment je
vais te manger mon crédit pour ma maison
il vient d'être accepté
ils ont des enfants ils ont enfin alors
vous avez créé avec vos collègues
artisans boulangers de toute la France
avait créé le weekend dernier collectif
dans un groupe facebook avec pour faire
entendre votre voix
des TPE
aujourd'hui juste on a vu hier le 4
Julien qui lui ça y est le pot moi je
j'ai pensé et je pense que vous avez
tous pensé hier soir je viens depuis
dimanche c'est fini pour eux enfin c'est
fini ça y est il a fermé sa boulangerie
et on a peur pour pas que les
boulangeries mais ça va boulangerie et
tous les petits commerçants ça va tomber
les uns après les autres qui dit il faut
trouver une solution très très vite pour
ça que je voulais qu'ils avaient soit là
ce soit parce que on veut des
témoignages on veut que les personnes et
les décideurs voient chez qui voilà il y
a beaucoup qui regardent l'émission qui
voit que c'est du concret et que ça va
tomber tous les jours tous les jours il
y a des gens qui vont tomber Isabelle
elle tiendra pas elle peut tenir une
année elle tiendra pas une année de plus
ça ne passera pas 2023
également par l'intermédiaire de DFC des
contrats
creuses des heures super creuses les
heures supers creuses c'est de 3h à 6h
mais moi qui ai une boulangerie où je
travaille en saisonnier l'été en fait
enfin voilà moi mes fous ils sont
allumés de 3 heures du matin à 10h 11h
mais donc les autres heures elles sont
explosées quoi enfin c'est de la folie
de 18 centimes le plus cher qu'on payait
le kilowatt-heure on est à 57 centimes
ils sont x 10 pour ceux qui sont chez
Total énergie tous les fins tous les
revendeurs en fait mais les factures il
y a plus rien de régler vraiment une
urgence chaque jour qui passe chaque
semaine chaque mois qui passe mais là
l'échéance moi elle est au 31 octobre au
31 décembre c'est toi pour tout le monde
c'est comment on fait comment on fait
pas pour tout le monde
William un bougeant un boulanger de Lyon
lui ça a commencé en septembre donc en
fait les accords qu'il a trouvé c'est
que sa facture de octobre il appelle sur
octobre novembre décembre et puis bah
celle de novembre c'est décembre janvier
février mais à trois mois il y a 11000
euros par mois pour un local enfin moi
ma baguette je pourrais jamais la vendre
5 euros
même s'il est plus mais un croissant
allait ça vaut entre 95 et 1,50 à 82
euros peut-être dans les bonnes
pâtisseries mais voilà moi j'ai quatre
produits en fait donc sur quatre
produits je pourrais pas augmenter
d'autant je pourrais jamais répercuter
cette hausse un supermarché pour être
sur 10000 produits ça se verra beaucoup
moins mais nous ça c'est la mort du
petit commerce mais
s'ils avaient voulu le faire
on va prendre des exemples concrets
sachez-le tout la semaine la semaine
prochaine et tout le mois de janvier on
veut des exemples tous les jours pour
que ça bouge et pour que compreniez là
voilà là on a eu l'exemple de 22000 à 90
000 euros c'est fini c'est mort
pas d'autres métiers je suis d'accord si
je peux me permettre
tout le monde mais mon voisin qui est
artisan également commerçant qui est
bouché il a pas d'efforts alors nous
aussi on a des frigos on a des chambres
froides on a des vitrines et évidemment
que la note elle va s'augmenter mais
jamais dans les proportions des
proportions
ils ont la chance et honnêtement c'est
une chance et il y a aussi quelques
boulangers qui sont dans ce cas là
d'être avec des compteurs 36 kg et 36 kg
en fait le gouvernement a eu quand même
l'intelligence de mettre un bouclier
tarifaire comme pour les particuliers à
15%. mais nous jaune on est moi mon four
il fait 42 kg donc le 36 je rentrerai
pas mais mon voisin il est à 36 donc il
aura 15 % d'augmentation et une
entreprise comme la mienne 15% elle les
absorbe sans problème
300 400 500 c'est pas possible 1000%, ça
existe pas dans la vraie vie demain on
va se descend il a 10 €, ça n'existe pas
bah voilà ça n'existe pas on ne peut pas
donc on va et il y a pas voilà je vous
dis on recevra des gens tous les jours
en tout cas merci
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure du groupe
des artisans TPE donc on est à neuf
boulanger et honnêtement ça fait du bien
et je voudrais lancer un appel à ceux
qui semblent seuls parce que dans notre
groupe des fois ça va mais des fois ça
va pas parce que ce qu'on se rend pas
compte non plus c'est quand on est
artisan bah moi mon commerce c'est ma
retraite je suis allé sur mon compte
retraite et j'ai le droit à 67 ans
royalement 800 euros de retraite donc en
fait ma retraite c'est mon centre
demain avec un RB e négatif avec un fond
de commerce que je vais fermer
une retraite j'en aurai pas j'ai 5
enfants
on travaille avec mon mari enfin depuis
toujours et
c'est pas normal en fait on n'a pas le
droit de
j'aime pas me plaindre mais non mais
au secours quoi
c'est le pain qu'il faut protéger tu
vois c'est l'aliment de base c'est le
truc qui doit être normalement le moins
cher et accessible à tous
la boulangerie qui met la baguette à
l'Unesco mais qui laisse mourir
ils font rien pour nous je pense qu'on
va créer une association
faut protéger le pain quoi il y a pas
que il y a plein une fois de plus faut
sauver les boulangers c'est vrai mais il
y a aussi d'autres métiers il y a les
restaurateurs avec les chambres
tout le monde entier on aide le monde
entier une fois de plus j'allais dire
que je suis fou mais on aide le monde
entier en balance des sous dans le monde
entier et regardez cette dame qui a
travaillé toute sa vie qui est là que sa
boulangerie elle est là elle pleure sur
un plateau de télé mais on est en France
on est où là on est en France on est où
c'est ils font quoi avec les sous des
gens ils prennent les sous des gens ils
font quoi avec si c'est pas pour aider
alors là c'est pas c'est pas l'Ukraine
c'est pas il va faire froid cet hiver
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit moi mais par
contre il va faire froid cet hiver les
autres années faisaient froid quand même
et vous il y avait pas des gens comme
vous qui venaient pleurer pour pour leur
sur leur situation 70 000 €
d'électricité 90000 non en France 90 000
sur 2 sites sans augmentation je parle
dans la 78
c'est n'importe quoi
tu ne peux pas t'en sortir Isabelle bah
on reviendrai vous voir quand vous
voudrez et on va faire un essai pour
vraiment il faut que ça bouge faut
trouver des solutions très très vite
pour les plus touchés sinon ça va tomber
merci de nous recevoir s'il faut une
autre fois et beaucoup d'autres
personnes parce que c'est important
merci Isabelle merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]